WILL BIDEN RECOVER?
WILL THE OBAMA COALITION CANNOT
DISAPPOINT HIM?
THAT’S YET TO BE DETERMINED.
>> Sean: LAWRENCE JONES ON THE
GROUND IN IOWA TONIGHT.
DURING MY EXCLUSIVE SUPER BOWL
SITDOWN INTERVIEW WITH THE
PRESIDENT, I DID ASK HIM ABOUT
THE MEDIA’S DISDAIN FOR HIS
SUPPORTERS AND WORKING-CLASS
AMERICANS.
I SPECIFICALLY BROUGHT UP WHAT
WE ALL WITNESS AND SHOCK WITH
CNN FAKE NEWS DON LEMON, WHOSE
RECENT EFFORTS TO DEGRADE TRUNK
VOTERS, HERE’S WHAT THE
PRESIDENT HAD TO SAY.
HE SAW DON LEMON THIS PAST WEEK
ON THE LAUGHING BASICALLY AT
TRUMP SUPPORTERS.
SMELLY TRUMP WALMART SHOPPERS,
IRREDEEMABLE’S DEPLORABLES,
AMERICANS, THE COMMENT OBAMA
MADE.
BITTER AMERICANS WHO CLING TO
THEIR BIBLE, THEIR GOD, AND
RELIGION.
IT SEEMS LIKE THERE IS A
CONTEMPT FOR PEOPLE TO DON’T
SHARE THEIR WORLDVIEW.
>> President Trump: I WATCH
THIS GUY.
HE’S A TERRIBLE -- HE’S NOT A
SMART PERSON.
AT ALL.
I WATCH THAT PHONY LAUGH.
HE WAS TRYING TO ACT, PUTS HIS
HEAD DOWN.
THERE WAS NOTHING FUNNY ABOUT
WHAT WAS SAID.
>> Sean: HERE WITH REACTION,
FORMER ARKANSAS GOVERNOR,
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE HIMSELF,
KATIE PAVLICH IS WITH US.
IRREDEEMABLE DEPLORABLES, SMELLY
WALMART SHOPPERS, GUILTY.
GUILTY, GOD, BIBLES, GUILTY.
GUILTY AS CHARGED.
WHAT DOES THIS TELL US ABOUT
WHAT PEOPLE IN THE ESTABLISHMENT
ELITE CLASS IN D.C. AND
NEW YORK, L.A., SAN FRANCISCO,
THINK ABOUT WE THE PEOPLE?
>> THEY LIVE IN THEIR BUBBLES
AND THEY REALLY DON’T GET OUT
MUCH AND THEY DON’T UNDERSTAND
THE REST OF THE COUNTRY.
ALL THEY ARE DOING IS DRIVING
MORE SUPPORT TO PRESIDENT TRUMP
FOR HIS REELECTION.
THEY INSULTED OVER 80 MILLION
AMERICANS WITH THAT KIND OF
STUFF AND DON LEMON GIGGLING
LIKE AN 8-YEAR-OLD GIRL AND HIS
BIRTHDAY PARTY.
I’VE NEVER SEEN ANYTHING QUITE
AS RIDICULOUS.
CNN SHOULD HAVE CALLED AND SAID
YOU CAN’T BE A NEWS ANCHOR AND
FALL DOWN ON YOUR DESK AND
GIGGLE LIKE THAT.
IT’S UNPROFESSIONAL.
LET THEM DO WHAT THEY WANT TO
DO.
I’M TELLING YOU IT’S COMING BACK
TO BITE THEM.
>> Sean: PEOPLE AREN’T
WATCHING.
KATIE, WE LOOK AT RATINGS EVERY
DAY.
>> I SAW CNN BEING PLAYED AT THE
BERNIE RALLY THERE, SEAN, AND
WAS THINKING THEY ARE ACTUALLY
GETTING MILLIONS OF EUROS
TONIGHT BECAUSE THEY WERE
PLAYING IN THE BACKGROUND.
I THINK ONE OF THE MOST
IMPRESSIVE AND IMPORTANT
MESSAGES THE PRESIDENT HAS
GOTTEN OUT THERE WHO IS THAT
IT’S NOT THAT THEY JUST HATE
HIM.
THEY HATE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
WHO VOTED FOR HIM.
THEY ARE JUST IN THE WAY.
THEY SAY THAT ON THE CAMPAIGN
TRAIL.
25% OF DEMOCRATS.
>> Sean: I IMAGINE THAT THEY
HAVE TO SAY THE WORDS.